failed former president Donald Trump
who's been indicted twice and impeached
twice and may be indicted one two or
three more times is now wildly accusing
President Joe Biden of cocaine use this
happened on his platform truth social
the back story here is that there was
cocaine found in a visitor's area of the
White House right-wing media quickly
jumped to suggest that it might be
Hunter Biden's Fox News host Brian
kilmead suggested it might be laced with
fentanyl they pronounce it fentanyl
whatever you know what they're talking
about
um and now the failed former president
is saying maybe it was Biden's trothing
on Troth Central quote was crooked Joe
Biden on cocaine why is cocaine
capitalized we don't know was crooked
Joe Biden on cocaine when he instructed
the FBI doj to illegally invade my home
aralago in complete and total violation
of my fourth amendment rights was he on
Capital C cocaine or various other
substances when he for the first time in
U.S history had his political opponent
who was leading him in the capital P
polls by a lot indicted and arrested
twice if you include the doj Run
Manhattan DA's office we are a nation in
Decline Capital all capital letters
here's my translation this one is a very
easy one to translate
Justice might be approaching me
I may be held accountable for my actions
and I am really really scared people
asked me David could this be defamation
against Joe Biden I didn't even talk to
a lawyer about this one it seems very
hard to imagine how a figure as public
and powerful and as well protected as
the President of the United States could
successfully sue Trump for defamation
even at the suggestion that he is on
cocaine now I want to mention one other
thing and this of course this is when
the conspiracy theories conflict on the
one hand the right is saying that Biden
has absolutely no energy he he looks the
opposite of coked up in every public
appearance and at the same time Trump is
suggesting without evidence that Biden
might be using cocaine don't you think
that if Biden was using cocaine he would
be more energetic rather than less
energetic I don't know just a question
that I'm asking but the again this is
where we are this is the former
president of the United States asserting
without any evidence suggesting without
evidence that the current president of
the United States who beat him by many
votes nationally maybe using cocaine if
you're like me and you love The
Nostalgia of enjoying a bowl of cereal
sometimes as an adult check out our
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon is the
breakfast cereal with the crunchy sweet
goodness you love but with zero grams of
sugar more protein and only four to five
net carbs so it's perfect if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto if
you're like me and you just don't want
to eat a bunch of sugar magic spoon has
delicious flavors to choose from cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter Honey Nut
cinnamon roll birthday cake my favorite
is maple waffle and right now they have
limited edition spring flavors
strawberry milkshake and peaches and
cream sometimes you just feel like
sitting down with a bowl of cereal when
the mood strikes go for something with
plenty of protein
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman create a custom
bundle use the code Pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below